what people ask you to do as a favor is
an indication of the things you can
charge for later if you've got stuff
that people ask you to do for them
because you're good at it maybe you're
good at Tech it's like can you help me
set up my like Wi-Fi and stuff you know
blah blah it's like that means you're
solving problems I had all these people
who are asking me for programs and stuff
and so what I did was during my last
year of Consulting I started something
called the free training project I would
charge 500 to a thousand dollars I
wouldn't charge it they had to donate
that to the charity their choice in
exchange to work with after a year of
doing that I had probably 12 really
great before and after pictures once I
had that I transitioned many of those
customers said hey I'm going to do this
full-time now are you comfortable paying
the same amount you're paying to charity
except just making a charity of Alex
because Alex can't eat either all I had
was an LLC and a PayPal account so like
for everybody's like I don't know how to
start a business you literally just need
a bank account and a way to process
money that is it